[Music]
welcome to the live stream a huge huge
story that I started getting emails from
people saying I wasn't going to talk
about this story which is insane of
course I'm going to talk about this
story and these are the major
allegations from former interim DNC
chair donna Brazile about hillary
clinton effectively stealing the
Democratic Party nomination and I'm
gonna get into you know I'm gonna take
it all from the top and we're gonna have
plenty of time here to get into the
details of this and I'm glad you're
joining me here today because this is
just an absolute huge huge story if this
is your first live stream with me
welcome it's really live unlike the
clips that we upload to YouTube which
have clearly been previously recorded
this is live unless you're watching a
replay you can communicate directly with
me I can read your comments and respond
to them I can answer questions you might
have the best two ways to send those in
are to use super chat which is the
dollar sign at the bottom of the YouTube
chat window you can also go to stream
lapse calm / the David Pakman show super
chat takes about 30% stream Labs does
not stream labs just takes about 3% so
that's an option both are available to
you and feel free to send questions and
comments and while I'm talking about the
DNC stuff and I will get to all of them
after that I promise you new members and
patrons get live thank-yous during the
stream that includes if you sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership that
includes if you make a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show now
I did figure out on yesterday's stream I
got this thing set up where see where it
says over here where is it pledged right
there pledged $91 and then little
animations play over here we finally got
it hooked up with patreon and then all
1,900 something current patreon
contributions were popping up one after
the other and I spoke to Stream Labs
about it which runs the graphics for our
streams and they said that this is a
glitch that they're dealing with that
what
happens is that basically the way
patreon works the first of the month
patrons are charged everybody who's an
active patron on the first day of the
month is charged and the stream labs
integration sees that as all brand-new
pledges so it actually ran through and I
ran overnight even after the stream was
over now 1987 of those but now it seems
like it's it's done and we should only
be seen up here actual new patreon
contributions that happen during the
during the live stream now as far as
patreon goes this is from today's bonus
show we have now set up and this will be
my buddy during the broadcast show a
Jenga game on the David Pakman show
studio desk and starting effective
immediately in fact effective last night
we are going to be turning patreon
contributions into a Jenga related game
where I will be moving pieces for people
that make patreon contributions and when
the entire thing ultimately comes down
depending on how many pieces I'm able to
move there will be a major major
membership discount so that that's
already happening just so you know and I
actually did a test game today on the
bonus show so if you did not watch
today's bonus show if you are a member
if you're not a member and you sign up
definitely check out today's bonus show
david pakman.com slash cryptocurrency to
learn about the amazing reality that we
are now accepting cryptocurrency and
please don't troll the live chat I
actually had to ban someone before the
stream even started it's pathetic
right absolutely and totally pathetic
and we do have now that I'm focused on
the discussion we do have moderators in
there okay so let's talk about what's
going on with the DNC the I'm gonna go
through this story in detail but to
begin with I as soon as the story broke
I started getting emails from people
saying David you will never talk about
it because you're a shill there's posts
on our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it people saying
david you won't admit that hillary
clinton stole the DNC the Democratic
primary because either I guess I'm some
such
major Hillary supporter even though I
voted for Bernie Sanders in the primary
that I won't I won't talk about that or
whatever there's one reason I didn't
talk about the Donna Brazile story on
today's program which is the program was
already in production when the story
broke the article published on Politico
does it say here I'm linking to the
article in the description doesn't say
what time it was published but needless
to say we sort of decide on stories for
the show a lot the night before and then
a little bit the morning of the show was
done we were already taping the show
we're about to tape the show when this
story broke so there was no reason
whatsoever that I would not talk about
this I've talked about Bernie Sanders
getting screwed by the DNC I've talked
about the DNC strategically scheduling
debates or not scheduling them the ones
many of them just not scheduled
eventually they had to schedule more
debate scheduling them at particular
times when viewership would be lower
I've talked about so many ways Hillary
Clinton in Nevada working out sharing
office space with the DNC it the DNC was
not an unbiased arbiter of the
Democratic primary I've never hidden
that I've never hidden that I supported
Bernie Sanders in the primary and I've
also never hidden that on November I am
now I'm forgetting was it November 8th
of 2016 on election day I did cast a
vote for Hillary Clinton because based
on the candidates that were running at
that time that's who I decided to vote
for it it has nothing to do with wanting
to hide realities about the DNC or
anything like that okay so let's now get
into the story what is the story
what we have learned today from an
article that Donna Brazile interim
former interim DNC chair wrote on
Politico she says that she ran she
conducted an investigation into did
Hillary Clinton co-op to the DNC in
order to defeat all challengers during
the Democratic primary of 2016 and Donna
Brazile claims that she uncovered a
financial scheme for Hillary Clinton to
do exactly that
how does Hillary Clinton pull this off
according to Donna Brazile well it
really comes down to fundraising
it comes down to fundraising the limits
for donations to individual individual
candidates during election cycles are
far lower than what one can trick can
contribute to the DNC and in fact
because the DNC has all of these
different state parties if you
contribute the maximum to each DNC state
party and the National DNC you as an
individual can contribute way more money
than you ever could just to the
committee the campaign to elect Hillary
Clinton for example so what Donna
Brazile says she uncovered and she
outlines this not only in this article
today in Politico but also in a new book
that she has out and that is something
I'm going to talk about there's no
believe me it's not lost on me that they
that she has an incentive to want to
sell books here
she says that Hillary Clinton basically
struck a deal with the DNC and Donna
Brazile says and outlines that she found
a document that explains this it's not
just her pulling this out of thin air
she says that Hillary Clinton arranged
with the DNC that number one she she
being her campaign would be in control
of the finance excuse me of the finances
the money received by the DNC but also
that the DNC would effectively launder
money for Hillary Clinton
meaning that donations would come into
the DNC the DNC would get to keep a
little bit of that and then the lion's
share of the money would go back out to
the Hillary Clinton campaign now if
Hillary Clinton were already the
Democratic nominee that would not be
that unusual as Donna Brazile explains
in the political article that I'm
linking to in the am i yes actually I'm
linking to the Newsweek article let me
change the link right now in the
description here okay I've updated it
that would be a pretty normal thing if
Hillary Clinton had already been
declared had already won the Democratic
nomination the problem is that this
fundraising scheme was in place before
the dot the nomination was settled
meaning that you had Bernie Sanders and
at other points other Democrats
individuals running for the Democratic
primary competing but the DN C Mon
was being a lion's share of it was being
kicked back out to Hillary Clinton that
is effectively a money-laundering scheme
and a dishonest one and as Donna Brazile
says in her article in Politico there is
nothing illegal about this in the sense
that we're talking about a political
party that party establishes its rules
it purports to be an unbiased arbiter of
the Democratic primary it doesn't have
to be it's not a question of legality
but clearly it was not and that is what
Donna Brazile says that she uncovered
the money supposedly for the eventual
candidate was in advance being given to
the Hillary Clinton campaign if true
this is nothing short of monumental now
should we have some degree of skepticism
about Donna Brazil's assertions of
course we should of course we should and
it has nothing to do with who you
supported now then Trump Russia
Bernie whatever we should always have a
healthy skepticism of what we are being
told and when it comes to Donna Brazile
there's a couple different things going
on number one she is trying to sell a
book and we know that she could have
gone public with this before in fact if
Donna Brazile had gone public with this
earlier it's possible that the DNC might
not be in the situation it's currently
in with Tom Perez an effectively
establishment Democrat running the DNC
it's possible that that would have gone
a different way but she wants to sell
books so she's decided that this is how
she's going to announce this but there's
another issue here as well which is that
in her declaration about what she found
out she being Donna Brazile about
hillary clinton's effective takeover of
the DNC donna Brazile says that had she
known about this she never would have
accepted the position of interim chair
at the DNC but she also effectively
throws debbie Wasserman Schultz under
the bus and says she had absolutely no
knowledge or involvement in this now do
we believe that I don't know
I genuinely don't know is this an effort
from Donna Brazile to save face in a
conveniently timed explanation that
coincides with the release of her book
it's possible
is it possible that Donna Brazile is
telling us the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth it's possible but
when you're talking about Democrats Inc
and Donna Brazile was part of the
Democrats Inc cabal from the point of
view of many Bernie supporters for a
long time the same people that believed
Donna Brazile to be a disastrous DNC
chair and not trustworthy many of them
are now buying into Donna Brazil's
new story 100% and all of that
skepticism they had of her has
evaporated now the way I like to
approach things is if I was skeptical of
Donna Brazile before why would i all of
a sudden not be skeptical now because
she may have confirmed a narrative that
i might have already believed or
suspected to be true so we we have to
express that skepticism and we have to
take everything that is said with a
grain of salt because everybody has an
agenda here now would it really shock
any of us that this is exactly true that
what Donna Brazile is alleging is
exactly the way it happened of course
not of course not because all along we
saw that the DNC implicitly and in some
cases explicitly was not running a
completely on a completely unbiased
primary that's abundantly clear so this
it's sort of like when we hear that
Donald Trump did something completely
unethical star family then we say well
does he have a history of being super
empathetic with people or does he have a
history of being a completely delusional
narcissistic sociopath if the shoe fits
wear it right so that this donna Brazile
story correlates perfectly with what we
already believed about the DNC now the
next layer of this and a lot of you
aren't going to like it and if you don't
like it send me send me a super chatter
stream lab's comment explaining what it
is that I'm saying that's wrong here I
think I just saw my electric bill down
here and I'm just realizing I've not
paid this thing Wow
hopefully this thing is not oh do in
five days okay good that got to get that
thing paid it was hidden under a whole
bunch of stuff over here on my desk I
hate to break it to the Bernie bros
this doesn't change anything about Trump
Russia collusion okay there is this idea
sometimes from Bernie bros that if they
acknowledge Trump Russia collusion that
it somehow is an attack on Bernie and it
props up Hillary okay now to me it
doesn't make any sense and I've talked
about this before but the logic of it is
as follows there are some who believe
that if you believe Trump Russia
collusion took place that that's the
reason Trump defeated Hillary meaning
were it not for Russian collusion
Hillary would have won meaning that
Hillary was a great candidate that's
like ten steps that you don't need to
take the Trump Russia collusion story
and the DNC defending Hillary story
nothing objectively changes the merits
of Bernie Sanders is candidacy or of
Hillary Clinton's candidacy or of Donald
Trump's candidacy period okay and the
Bernie bros who insist that Trump Russia
collusion can't be true because Hillary
is a disaster need to take a step back
and realize that these are two totally
separate unrelated stories please stop
sending me the email saying that by
talking about Trump Russia collusion I
am chilling for Hillary Clinton
they are unrelated stories to the extent
that they indicate the sort of political
validity or our evaluation of Hillary
Clinton as a candidate I believe that
Bernie Sanders was the best candidate I
voted for Bernie Sanders in the
Democratic primary he ultimately lost
and yes the DNC had a big role to play
in him losing but that is completely
separate from the fact that we now have
three indictments in Trump Russia and
one guilty plea in Trump Russia this is
totally separate from the fact that Jeff
Sessions every day we learn more and
more about how he appears to have
perjured himself right
you've got to disaggregate the two
because there are two completely
different things two completely
different things
okay and and even now there are people
in the chat saying
I'm shilling for Hillary what what am I
saying that's so great about Hillary I'm
telling you I think she was not a good
candidate I'm telling you that I think
that she is far too conservative she's
far too involved with the democrats in
corporate democrats stuff in what way am
i filling for hillary clinton please
explain to me specifically okay let me
see what's going on in the super chat
here a lot of people want to get
involved here jonathan tab has sent a $2
super chat saying david thanks for all
you do you're the best well thank you i
appreciate it brave new world has sent a
2 euro super chat david you are wrong on
all issues and avoid facts well that's
not an argument give me an issue I'm
wrong about tell me what facts I'm
ignoring I hope that was worth the 2
euro for you
engi bingi two thousand has sent a five
dollar super chat asking whether I
followed the purge in the DNC with the
delegates getting canned
only a little bit I need to read more
about that I've got some articles
bookmarked about that to take a look at
tomorrow ok
over at Stream labs calm / the David
Pakman show
Wayne from California has sent a $5
comment thank you for expressing your
opinion which is a breath of fresh air
well Thank You Wayne I appreciate it a
user contributing under the name Donna
Brazile with brazil misspelled has sent
a $4 stream lapse contribution saying
david just want to thank you for not
covering that fake news story about the
DNC Hillary is pleased with your
performance very very clever hope that
was worth $4 for you gigantic sent a $3
contribution via stream labs David how
many times a week do you get asked to
debate Kyle kolinsky on Russia chat
please press 1 if you want David to
debate Kyle I don't it I'm not noticing
it too often every once in a while I see
something like that I don't really know
what there is to debate because it's
there's an investigation going on and we
will eventually see what crimes if any
were committed what collusion took place
if any I don't know what the debate is
if the debate is what does it imply
about Bernie Sanders as a candidate my
answer would be nothing so I don't think
that that Kyle and I
really have too much to debate about
that as I've said before the existence
or nonexistence of Trump Russia
collusion has no bearing on whether
Bernie Sanders was the best candidate or
not during the Democratic primaries I
believe that he was and I've said it
before and I'll say it again okay
John Koster has sent a $2 super chat
thank you very much
Kieran JC has sent a $5 super chat how
do you define the term Bernie bro this
is bothering people I don't know I mean
you know that there's no particularly
good term to describe the so I voted for
Bernie Sanders in the Democratic primary
but I am NOT attached to conspiracy
theories about how that conspiracy
theories isn't even the right word but
the idea that we can't accept that Trump
Russia collusion may have taken place
because it's an attack on Bernie's
candidacy I consider those to be two
completely separate stories and I was
number one not a Bernie or buster I
think that that's one possible
characteristic of a so-called the Bernie
bro I was not someone who believed at
any point that if Russia helped Trump
win that that in any way devalued or
deal legitimized Bernie Sanders's
candidacy so the individuals who are
clinging to that idea I guess is what I
mean as Bernie bros it's not a technical
term it's not the most accurate term but
you know that that's more or less I
guess I would say what I'm describing
let me do a couple thank-yous okay I
don't want to fall behind on these david
pakman.com slash membership the
membership program is the number one
funding source for our show and we've
got a few new members that have signed
up just while we've been chatting here
and I do want to say a special thank you
to them because they're directly funding
our program Simon Johnson thank you so
much Julieta Fraser
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership eric bakker thanks Eric
really appreciate it and a Norman Walker
Norman Walker has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership we do have a
coupon code available for membership if
you're interested in a discount
you can put in the coupon code I voted
17 then you'll get the best of all
worlds you will get all the member
benefits including the bonus show you
will get a discount and you will also be
thanked on the live stream which is a
really really great thing over at
patreon we're still taking contributions
we had just a horrible first of the
month yesterday we were up to two
thousand nine patrons actually on
October 31st and what happened sadly on
the 1st of the month is that patreon
attempts to charge everybody who's
pledged and some fraction in our case
somewhere around 60 or so patrons had
credit cards that expired or were
otherwise declined on November 1st so we
were knocked all the way down to like
nineteen thirty-five or forty yesterday
patrons but we've built it back up we're
back up to 1987 we have reached and
surpassed my birth year of 1984 and we
are only thirteen patrons away from 2000
so here's what I want to do okay we've
been dancing around this 2,000 patron
thing for a while and if you look down
at the bottom left of the screen you'll
notice that it says when we reach 2,000
patrons David will do an entire
broadcast show with his hair untamed and
out of control okay we're only 13
patrons away this is what I'm talking
about and let's just get to 2000 let's
do it tonight let's put that goal to
rest and then move on to bigger and
better things and and and just be done
with it and what I will probably do is
Monday do the entire show with my hair
like this which could be embarrassing
but I think it'll be funny as well and
what would be really funny is we're also
starting this other thing where I now
have a Jenga
set joining me in the studio on the desk
and we are going to be making moves in
the Jenga game I will be moving pieces
corresponding to patreon contributions
that we get and it would just be like
the perfect storm I don't know if the
show could even survive it if Monday I
end up doing the entire show with my
hair like this and we have so many
patreon contributions that the Jenga set
falls and crashes while we are taping
the show I don't know that the show
could survive it
it could be a it could be a scandal of
epic proportions but that's the goal for
tonight okay let's just get to 2000 if
we do that let's let's pull out all the
stops okay if we get to 2000 patrons
tonight and we're only like 11 away at
this point or something like that
I will create a 55% membership discount
code and only announce announce it to
you we will be locked in for doing the
show with the wacked out of control hair
and I will do thank yous for everybody
okay so let's just get it done I think
we can do it
Quinn Maliki has sent a oh no let's see
John Koster has sent a $2 super chat
thanks David you're right on the money
smart thanks John appreciate it
Quinn Maliki has sent the $5 super chat
a nation article claims the downloading
speeds DNC files were downloaded that
were higher than those that any ISP
could have provided to international
hackers what are your thoughts I've not
heard that Quinn and I offhand I don't
know enough I don't know enough about it
to say for sure but I'll look into it
beard man has sent a $2
super chat and beard man has been called
into jury duty and he's calling it BS
and a waste of time I was just called in
to jury duty myself I got the notice a
couple days ago and I've moved it
because the date isn't convenient and I
pushed it all out all the way till next
December almost a full year or more than
a year actually no less than a year
because it wasn't scheduled until
January or something like that my I did
jury duty once on my 21st birthday in
fact and it was an assault and battery
case and it destroyed my faith in the
justice system sadly because we were to
do it was a self-defense case we were to
decide as a jury whether an individual
who punched another individual was
acting out of self-defense or not right
now the facts of the case were that
individual a had shoved individual be
individual B had retaliated by punching
individual
a and the line Massachusetts as it was
explained to us for self-defense was
that it is only self-defense if you had
no means of exiting the situation
altogether you have sort of a duty to
retreat in the state of Massachusetts
and based on the facts of the case the
individual be who was on trial had many
options other than punching guy a in the
face so by the letter of the law it was
not self-defense but in the jury room
you had about half of the six I think it
was two or three of the six people in
the jury room couldn't understand that
we weren't talking colloquially about
self-defense we were talking about
self-defense has written by the letter
of the law so to two of the guys in
there interesting that it was two men
out of the I think that we had four men
and two women in the jury room two men
said no come on it was self-defense
it wasn't he's not guilty right I mean
guy I shoved him and guy B punched him
it was in self-defense he had been
shoved and those of us who understood
the jury instructions about the
definition of self-defense under the law
said we'll hold on it's only
self-defense if he had no ability to
retreat and because of all these
circumstances that were relevant to the
case he could have retreated and he
didn't so it's not self-defense and
these two guys insisted now come on if
someone shoves you what are you gonna do
it's self defense and ultimately we
found the guy not guilty not because we
were deadlocked but because we went to
the judge with some questions and we
said judge are we to decide merely if
the punch was self-defense assuming that
the the shove is part of the basis here
in other words are we are we to assume
that the shove or are we to even
evaluate whether we believe that the
shove took place and the judge basically
came back and said no your to decide if
any of the testimony that you've heard
is true and once we were told that that
it we had to first even assess whether
we believe the shove took place that
created a reasonable doubt and
ultimately it was not guilty and the
entire thing was a waste of an entire
day so anyway that's my that's my jury
duty story Frank macwrite has sent the
$20 super
setting the high-water mark for
tonight's stream just a theory maybe
Donald Trump still has 38 percent
support because Republicans are waiting
to see if he gets away with everything I
think this would change how they
campaign in the future if they know the
bar and expectations are much lower the
thing about that Frank is your
explanation would make sense in terms of
why we're public and elected officials
haven't jumped ship on Trump but it
would not really explain why the general
public hasn't jumped ship on Trump so I
think it's you're definitely on to
something but I don't I think it applies
to the elected officials not to the
voters X X Jamaica has sent a
five-dollar super charge Jorge Zoro's
needs to fund you lol I know lame joke
can't wait for mm by the way you should
have Pat at least once on a live stream
yeah I know people think Pat's always
around but Pat and I actually don't live
together shocking I know to a lot of
people but maybe someday he'd be able to
join me Rigo Ordonez has sent a $5 super
chat I've read in the New York Times in
the Wall Street Journal among others
that emoluments doesn't apply to elected
officials only government employees what
are your thoughts love the show TQM
what's TQM I forget what that means
what's that abbreviation for total
quality management now that can't
possibly be it I don't remember
anyway TQM thank you I think from what
I've read it does I'm not a lawyer but
from what I've read the emoluments
Clause does apply to elected officials
as well as government employees John
Koster has sent a $2 super chat has any
major Network recruited you I've had
meetings with major networks about being
a contributor the meetings were very
awkward and it was abundantly clear
within the first two minutes that I was
not a fit at least not with the people
who were talking to me and that's okay I
don't mind that
okay let me do a couple thank-yous here
we have a couple of new patrons Austin
Roberts has pledged $2 thanks very much
Austin I appreciate that Chris minore
has also pledged $2 at patreon.com slash
david pakman show maybe it's maybe it's
mean
I don't know if I pronounced that
incorrectly if so I apologize we are at
1990 patrons the challenge for tonight
let's just get to 2,000 let's do it if
we get to 2,000 I will have a bunch of
Jenga moves to make for each of those
patreon contributions on the program
upcoming if we get to 2,000 patrons we
will do an entire show from the
broadcast studio with my hair completely
out of control which i think will be an
interesting thing and every single one
of you will get a thank you so we
started at 1987 we're at 1990 we can do
this right we can do this let's just get
there and be done with it and I think we
will all we'll all be the better for it
right something like that over at stream
labs.com slash the david packard show
ash farther has sent a ten dollar
contributions how do you think the DNC
will respond to this news or deny it and
do you think Hillary Clinton DBS I don't
know if you meant a DBS maybe DWS debbie
debbie Wasserman Schultz or Bernie
Sanders will reply or say anything at
all based on the little you've read
about the DNC staffing issue do you
think this complicates their position
yeah the the DNC or as I call it
Democrats Inc they are in a tough
position right now and I have no idea
what they're going to comment as far as
I read up to 45 minutes ago they had not
yet commented and I could not possibly
predict what it is that they're going to
do but I will be watching closely and
it's going to be a fascinating couple of
weeks gigantic cent to $3 stream Labs
contribution David if you were ever
arrested what would your friends and
family think the reason was you know I
have been arrested I told the story of
when I was 7 months short of my 21st
birthday and I was arrested for holding
a beer at a party and I won't retell the
entire story but it is on
it's it's I've told it a couple times in
the on the bonus show and in other video
clips I think that are publicly
available on YouTube so yeah I have told
that and and I think that if I were to
be arrested again I think most people
that know me would assume that they
would think that the reason was some
kind of misunderstanding to be quite
frank indigo indigo sent a $2.00 stream
Labs contribution what's your opinion on
a long-form interview live in studio
with Richard Wolff topics of interest
for me would include new developments in
Marxian economics what Marxism in the
21st century looks like and what lessons
can we learn from the Soviet Union yeah
we've talked about some of those issues
we've sort of danced around some of them
and talked about them a little bit the
the issue with an in-studio interview
with Richard Wolffe who's my former
economics professor from my
undergraduate alma mater at the
University of Massachusetts is that he's
based in New York and we're based in
Boston so that's gonna be tough let's
see what else we've got here but I would
love to do it I would love to have him
and if he if he ever speaks in Boston it
would be my pleasure to have him in
Trent Tanner has sent to stream labs
calm slash the david pakman show
contribution cable company's lost a
million customers last quarter do you
think they can adapt to the changing
market absolutely a couple different
things going on number one YouTube D
monetization is going to push more money
to the cable companies that's number one
so they that that's been a big boon for
them since March 31st it's crushed us
it's been great for them the rollback of
net neutrality
could be a big boon for cable companies
and something else that could be good
for them and that what what the cable
companies are doing is they're by and
large
rethinking their offerings not so much
as dividing cable and internet but
thinking of it all is content delivery
and that is going to be sort of the
basis I believe for how they are going
to try to continue raising revenues in
addition to just constantly increasing
prices and raising fees and all of that
nuns
that you and I are pretty familiar with
at this point so I think that
cord-cutting is going to be a problem in
the short term in the medium term for
these companies but more than likely in
the long term they are going to adapt
and be able to make a ton of money
that's just the reality they're going to
be able to do it okay a couple more
comments coming in here
Matthew cummings has sent a five-dollar
super chat and then [ __ ] 68 has
donated 20 British pounds suit through
super chat that is now the top
contribution a frank macwrite donated
$20 but 20 British pounds I believe
right now the British Pound is still
stronger than the dollar right yes yes
it is that Wow bide up by quite a bit
quite a bit more than I remember it so
that is now the high-water mark 20
British pounds Mathew Cummings asking
when people ask you to debate Kyle on
Russia they're referring to Kyle
completely denying any Trump Russia
collusion and his ridicule of those who
asserted okay I didn't know that I don't
know how anyone can deny the collusion
the investigation is not over right and
also collusion means collusion in and of
itself is not a crime right collusion is
an umbrella term that can include
activities that could be criminal and
activities that might not necessarily be
criminal so I don't know how anyone can
say at this point that there was no
collusion it's just not been
demonstrated we just we just don't know
that that's uh I don't know how I don't
know how anybody could do that Chase
Bemis has sent a five-dollar super Chad
David what's your opinion of modern
monetary theory yeah I got a question
about this last week or the week before
and the idea is modern monetary theory
as I understand it effectively says that
the concept of currency and debt is sort
of irrelevant when you can just print
money if I if my recollection is correct
about modern monetary theory that's the
that's a big tenant
and I don't know enough about it and
I've been reading a little bit about it
since other people have mentioned it but
I'm not yet well-versed enough in it to
really comment intelligently but I
continue to research that along with a
number of other topics that are relevant
to me okay we've got a couple other
patreon contributors and of course we
are trying to get to two thousand
tonight we want to get to two thousand
contributors on patreon tonight and when
that happens it's going to be a trifecta
I will number one create a 55%
membership discount code just for you
number two I will be doing a show out of
the studio with my hair like this when
we get to 2,000 patreon contributions
and we are now gamifying patreon
contributions we will tie patreon
contributions to me making Jenga moves
we established today at the David Pakman
show studio a Jenga blow-up not a board
a Jenga set I don't know what it's
called I guess it's a set a set up and
we will be gamifying patreon
contributions by thanking people as I
make moves and we will see how many
Jenga moves I can make so anyway back to
the thank yous I want to thank Mario
Rodriguez who pledged Mario Rodriguez
canceled I don't know if that's an error
cancel like if they were trying to
cancel their contribution and
accidentally pledged or if that's part
of the eye we have a number of members
actually with the last name canceled
interestingly enough Mario Rodriguez
canceled has pledged two dollars a month
on patreon Katie bet it sure I don't
know if I'm pronouncing that correctly
has made a $2.00 a month pledge on
patreon and that gets us now we started
the evening at 1987 which was an
interesting year and we are now up to
1992 we are eight patrons away eight
patrons away from hitting two thousand
which is the goal for tonight I've got a
good feeling about tonight I've got a
good feeling about tonight I think we
might do this and it would be a
major major accomplishment particularly
because some of you may not have seen
this but amazon killed our affiliate
link on Monday and this happened to a
bunch of people jen briny I was tweeting
with Jen briny who hosts the
Congressional dish podcast she got her
Amazon link destroyed the same day we
did and that was about 10% of our
revenue so anything we can make up even
with dollar at a time contributions on
patreon is much appreciated and a couple
new members as well that I want to say
hello to let me pull those up here
CJ chase CJ chase thanks very much for
signing up Thomas LaBelle Thomas LaBelle
thank you for signing up and Esteban
Moore Esteban Moore has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership thank
you thank you thank you really
appreciate all of those contributions
and a lot of a lot of exciting stuff
coming for the program and I appreciate
everybody support John Koster has sent a
five-dollar super chat asking what do
you think is the real viability of a
third party system can anybody hear that
sounds like a phone calls coming through
my vent
I keep telling folks it's not a
possibility in the near future better to
reform the DNC here's the thing John I I
think we need to take an
all-of-the-above approach so to get
really viable third-party systems number
one I believe that we absolutely need
Instant Runoff voting that's going to
need to happen because the fear from
people for voting third party is too
great because let's say you're really
really far left if you vote for the
furthest left candidate you might end up
hurting the slightly left candidate and
helping the right wing candidate get
elected with Instant Runoff voting
you're able to say my number one choice
is candidate a my number two choices
candidate B and if it turns out that
after one run candidate a is not viable
to win then your vote is shifted to
candidate B it is a fantastic system
there are always some issues right there
are always some issues with any system
but I think that that needs to happen in
the meantime oh oh in campaign fine
perform as well right so that absolutely
needs to happen in order to make third
parties viable but in the meantime of
course we should be trying to reform the
DNC the the headline of this live stream
was that Donna Brazile former interim
DNC chair says hillary's stole the
election Hilary stole the Democratic
primary that is so absolutely we need to
be reforming the DNC as well Maria
Romero has sent a $2 super chat Thank
You Kelly
Noel has sent a $26 and 13 cent super
chat now how does that compare to 20
British pounds ah I see 20 British
pounds excuse me I'm having a very dry
throat issue here 20 British pounds was
26/11 in US Dollars and Katy Kelly has
sent 26 13 very clever I get it okay
farther has sent a $2 stream labs
contribution it was Debbie
wasserman-schultz
I always have oh boy I'm having like a
Fox News moment here it was Debbie
wasserman-schultz
wow this has never happened to me before
mm-hmm I have always had the initial
want to put the be from Debbie into the
acronym for whatever reason do you think
that within our lifetimes that atheists
mm-hmm can openly run for office and
have a chance just your opinion on that
subject um I think that atheism is
viable for national candidates mm-hmm
but it's gonna be a while I this is so
embarrassing okay
atheism is is more negatively seen at
this point then Marxism and communism so
I think that it is going to be possible
within our lifetimes if you're my age
but it's it's going to be a while okay
more patreon contributions Wow Wow
Courtney Hagler has just pledged $2 a
month
Karen Blake Robinson has pledged five
dollars a month and Daniel Ryan Day has
pledged two dollars per month we are now
at 1995 patrons we are five patrons away
from 2000 when we get to 2000 we will
have a number of things happen number
one I will do an entire broadcast show
with my hair like this and it could be
could be Monday I would say Monday might
be a good day for that in addition we
have set up Jenga on the David Pakman
show
desk at David Pakman show studios and we
will be making Jenga moves for each
patreon contribution now it might have
to be like two-to-one like for every two
contributions I thank two people and
then move to pieces because there's only
I believe 54 Jenga pieces and you can
usually get somewhere between 20 and you
know mid to high twenties moves before
the entire thing comes crashing down so
unless we want it to go super quickly I
think it's gonna have to be like a
two-to-one ratio and if we get to 2,000
patrons by the end of the evening I will
create and release for you a 55%
membership discount code I won't mention
it on the show
I won't email anybody I won't announce
it on Twitter
it will only be announced on this
livestream it'll be something you can
take advantage of a 55 percent discount
off of membership and we are only 5
patrons away you know I always wished
from the time I was a little boy that
the 2,000 patron milestone would happen
during a live stream and I just might
get that wish today because it is
looking very very good only five away
let's make it happen let's just wrap it
up and I'm actually gonna I'm so
confident it's going to happen I'm going
to pull up the coupon creation interface
for our website and membership right now
because I believe in you and I believe
that it's that it's going to happen and
it's going to be super exciting
Emmett Cashman has sent a five-dollar
super check if I'm okay with a Nazi
getting punched does that make me a
legitimate mass murdering Nazi no if you
if you're okay with Nazis being punched
you're not a mass murderer and you're
not a Nazi but I sort of disagree with
you
there's my take on this okay you know
that phrase I disagree with what you've
said but I will defend to the death your
right to say it I think we should defend
all speech that is not inciting violence
but I'm not necessarily going to choose
to defend to the death the speech of
Nazis let other Nazis do that right I'll
focus on other projects I'm not going to
go out and put myself in front of people
looking to punch Nazis right but I do
think that as a matter of policy and as
a matter of ideals that punching Nazis
is not is not the way to go now the
counter-argument is that Nazi ideology
is so violent that it's kind of
indistinguishable from physical violence
like a punch
I just don't know that I see eye to eye
with people who believe that so I don't
believe we should be punching Nazis
unless you're defending yourself from
someone else's physical aggression in
which case it doesn't matter whether
there are Nazi or not you should just
defend yourself
gigantic has sent a $2.00 stream lapse
contribution what are your thoughts on
RT that bald guy from ring of fire who
hosted your show one time goes on RT are
they just Kremlin propaganda or a good
news source we do not use RT as a source
for any of our stories as a matter of
show policy we we it's just it's on the
list of new sources that we don't use
period and it is it's not a question of
it being an ad hominem of whether it's
Kremlin propaganda it is Russian state
media right it's funded it's it's
Russian it's funded by Russian oligarchs
and it is connected to the Kremlin so we
don't we don't use it as a source and
you know every but it's important that
everybody sort of check every source and
understand where where these what these
sources are sort of how they're financed
and what it means to you know see news
from any particular source ash farther
has sent a $2.00 stream Labs
contribution oh I forgot to mention
I'm writing a brief paper on whether or
not television is becoming obsolete
I assume that by television the meaning
is the amalgamation of the programs do
you know of any good studies going one
way or the other
nuke the fridge nuke the fridge I don't
know what that means
nuke the fridge never heard that before
urban dictionary new nuke the fridge
nuke the fridge is a colloquialism used
to refer to the moment in a film series
that is so incredible
then it lessens the excitement of
subsequent scenes that rely on more
understated action or suspense and it
becomes apparent that a certain
installment is not as good as previous
installments due to ridiculous or
low-quality storylines events or
characters I'm not sure exactly what you
are referring to with nuke the fridge I
understand the phrase now I don't know
I'm sorry but I don't know of any papers
about the possible obsolescence of
television if I did I can assure you I
would tell you about it
maria romero with a $10 super chat i
usually miss your live streams glad i
got to this one always good to see you
maria maria is a David Pakman show
all-star she contributes to be a super
chat she's a member and she contributes
via patreon so I couldn't thank Maria
enough and it's always always great to
see you Maria thank you so much I've got
another patron to thank we're getting
dangerously close to 2,000 Kelly Nowell
has sent it to has pledged $2.50 a month
on patreon I actually I don't think I
knew that you could do pennies I thought
it had to be full dollars on patreon but
thank you so much really really
appreciate that and we are now at 1996
you guys aren't gonna let us fall short
right and and just fall for shorts for
short of 2000 I really hope that doesn't
happen that would be a bummer I'm ready
to go here with a 55% discount code for
membership if we hit 2000 if we hit 2000
i think Monday we will be doing an
entire broadcast show with my hair like
this from the studio if we hit 2000 we
we'll have close to 20 possible Jenga
moves to make in studio as well we now
have a Jenga gamification of patreon
contributions let's not fail let's not
fail let's let's make it happen because
I think it would be a really really
great thing and we're only four away now
does anybody have a strong feeling
assuming that this happens what should
be the theme what should be the theme of
the coupon code I've made them things
like cucked no more I've made them
things like Donny boy this or that or
Donald Trump related things I feel like
it should maybe be indictment related
right I don't know I think that there
should be something like that
ok xx Jamaica I sent a $5 super chat
I heard the uranium one story that came
up recently was about targeting robert
muller since he was the FBI director
when uranium 1 when the uranium 1 deal
happened that's interesting i did hear a
couple things about that i you know i've
i've looked into the uranium story and
what is abundantly clear is that the
timing of starting to talk about it last
week was very clearly because there was
panic about exactly what it is that
happened this week which is multiple
indictments and a guilty plea and the
trump russia investigation so you might
be right
it there's endless reasons why that
might be something we're hearing about
right now the bun has sent a $5 super
shot the question is are you planning to
expand the show and include other
presenters higher reporters etc thanks
love what you do interesting question
that's something that we do think about
here and there but the truth is that
just running our show is a lot of work
and we could continue to improve the
David Pakman show
by staffing up and expanding the
production value and growing ad sales
and a lot of different things so there's
no there's no 100% decision on that
right now but but it's definitely
something that we think about E&D has
sent a $5 Super chat I'm already a
patron step
but people need to see that hair and
then rego or dounia's has sent a $2.00
super jet code TQM 2017 dakedo mucho
over okay love you very much in Spanish
got it got it got it rego shocking that
I didn't know that I think it's because
my brain was not engaged in Spanish mode
when I read it and it didn't even occur
to me that TQM was a was a Spanish
abbreviation Wow
we have another patreon contributor John
Koster has just pledged five dollars a
month on patreon we are now at 1997 1997
the target is 2000 and we've got about
ten minutes left in this live stream
because I got to go to bed got to go to
bed it's been a long week already and a
big big day tomorrow it's a school night
we're not gonna fall just three short
are we we are only three patrons away
here we started the evening at 1987 and
we are 1997 three patrons away let's do
it
XX jamaica with a $2.00
super chat maybe the patreon code should
be free caucus Stan a little too
difficult to spell and I think that that
would be confusing to people if that
were the coupon code what I need to
think of something clever though I
always in the I think about clever
coupon codes all the time except when I
actually need to create then maybe maybe
let's see I'm gonna type one in here
let's see yeah all right I've got an
idea I've got an idea
actually it's tough to spell that's the
problem you know what we're gonna make
it a difficult one to spell anyway
because then I'll if we make it I'll
paste it into the description for
everybody I really hope we do we do make
it to 2000 if we didn't at this point it
would just be so embarrassing because
I've already got a coupon code plan for
everybody
Oh code hairdo that's interesting it
could be hair related
let me try something that's a good idea
I like that it's gonna be a hair related
code but don't let me down let's make it
let's make it let me take a look at the
regular chat I always want to look in
and see what people are saying in the
regular chat it's not just for the
elites who are contributing contributing
be a super chat come on guys let's do
this says Maria Romero what do I think
about rick perry's statement suggesting
fossil fuels could reduce sexual
assaults in africa yeah i saw that i
will be talking about that either on
tomorrow or monday's program let's see
what else we have here the code should
be TQM 2017 the code should be no Russia
story the code should be what else are
people suggesting here a couple other
ones what other questions do we have
Russia Russia Russia agree with David
disagree with David it should be illegal
to be Christian and be president I think
that would be unconstitutional who are
you calling a Bernie bro Kyle kolinsky
is a Bernie bro jeez a lot of tension in
the chat today wasn't Bernie openly an
atheist now he wasn't he wasn't what I
described would describe is openly an
atheist but we could certainly read
between the lines
Russians are wiretapping you David I
really hope not but I assume that they
are cover some Canadian stories that's
an interesting idea
could do that every once in a while we
do seize the means of production that's
that's a good one I like that one a lot
of interesting discussion a lot of
interesting discussion happening there
and not not that many people banned
today which is interesting because
usually it's an absolute and total [ __ ]
show and yeah I mean it's just just
amazing Oh people people mentioning XCOM
uh we actually have a question coming up
on audience questions next week or the
next next week or the week after about
what video games I grew up playing and I
was a huge huge huge
XCOM player growing up XCOM and the
Grand Theft Auto series were like my
go-to x' in the video game world as well
as flight simulator
but I'll dig into that and maybe we'll
find out what producer Pat's favorite
games were growing up as well but I will
I will save getting more into that in
the future why did I leave the Young
Turks that's a good question from dark
mood you know I was never part of the
Young Turks I was part of the Young
Turks YouTube network which was really
like an administrative thing and we just
decided to go totally independent and to
grow the channel independent of all the
other Young Turks channels I still talk
to those guys just saw Erin why sake
from TYT in Vegas last week I saw
Jenkins steve-o in Vegas last week and I
had a chance to catch up with both of
them spoke to Jiang spoke to steve-o and
it was good to see them so it was not
for any reason other than decided to
just be completely independent and not
be associated with with that brand Dylan
Collett has sent a $2 super chat do I
consider myself a secular humanist you
know I I value secular humanism is a set
of values that I do identify with and
I'm actually going to be speaking on I
think it's the first Sunday in December
at Harvard's humanist hub let me say
yeah Sunday December 3rd I'm gonna be
speaking at Harvard's humanist hub about
free speech as a humanist value that's
open to the public by the way so feel
free to come come there and check out my
presentation so yeah I identify with
humanist values pretty significantly
although I don't know that I identify as
a secular humanist Yesenia Marino has
asked me at stream labs whether I'm
growing a mustache for Movember I
usually don't do that
but you know I haven't shaved so far in
November so maybe I should maybe I
should do that I'll let me see if I can
get permission from my girlfriend for
that kidding men Oh has sent a two-top
$2 stream super chat before calling it a
night
check your steam it so here's the deal I
am the david pakman show is now on steam
it steam it is a new platform it's very
exciting
and the David Pakman show today has
broken into steam it and my introduction
post on steam it and its steam it calm /
@ sign David Pakman steam it the ste MIT
dot-com /at David Pakman my introduction
post now has 117 up votes 38 comments
and has accrued 111 dollars and 43 cents
in I don't know what it's called is it
called revenue on steam it I'm not sure
but check it out it's a very cool new
platform and that is really really good
news Ian D has sent the $5 super chat
did you see Jen Kyogre debate Sam Harris
about Islam what is your opinion on the
matter yeah I think that's the three
hour video I did not watch all of it
that was a big big commitment I saw a
little bit of it it was years ago and I
don't remember the details but I think I
recall that I was not particularly
impressed by any the outcome was not
that anything was resolved in my view
yeah okay now I've just been I I
realized we made it to 2000 patreon
contributions I see people in the chat
going completely apoplectic saying David
David you you've made it you've made it
I know
I was just waiting this is a really big
deal we have now surpassed the 2,000
patron mark at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and the most exciting thing
about this is that when you now go to
patreon.com/scishow see how on the
screenshot I'm showing you it says that
it says 1987 out of 2000 and then when
we get to 2000 patrons I'll do an entire
show with my hair like this etc we've
talked about it because we've reached
2,000 patrons if you now go to
patreon.com/scishow
it now says out of 2,500 patrons and
this is a very exciting thing when we
reach 2500 patrons we are going to
record edit and upload all of my Boston
College lectures from my talk media
epistemology critical
thinking and media literacy class I know
it's shocking particularly when you see
this but I am a college professor at
Boston College and the 75 minute
lectures that I've been that I've given
there are something that people on on
the internet have expressed an interest
in seeing and we've decided that when we
get to 2500 patrons which is now the
next goal we've made it to 2000 when we
get to 2500 we will fully produce those
and make them available to you so let's
get a coupon code going thank you to
Daniel Crate who has pledged five bucks
a month
Sheryl Alvarez has pledged two dollars a
month ash farther has pledged two
dollars a month William Rees has pledged
two dollars a month
Samuel Medina has pledged two dollars a
month
Carlos Macias has pledged two dollars a
month thank you thank you thank you to
all of you we are now at 2003 patrons I
am NOT gonna have a choice on Monday
I've been promising it for months and
I'm gonna have to do it Monday I will
have to do the entire show with my hair
like this Monday Jenga pieces are going
to be moved for our patreon contributors
but most importantly I am now setting up
a coupon code which will save you fifty
five percent off of membership I'm not
telling anybody else other than you find
folks on the livestream about the coupon
code and the coupon code is hair 17
coupon code hair 17 I have just added it
to the description and it will save you
fifty five percent off of membership it
will expire in I think it's tomorrow at
midnight that it will expire so get
those memberships fifty five percent off
you get a hundred percent of the member
benefits and incredibly exciting thank
you to everybody I'd better start
getting my hair product ready so I can
puff up my hair as much as possible
that's the funny thing that this is this
is my hair with no product in it but I
actually know of a way to use the
product to puff it up even more and just
just for kicks
I might actually do that on the Monday
show so thanks to everybody have at it
with the coupon code thanks to everybody
who contributed and I will do another
live stream very soon